segundo día de audiencias con miras a
confirmar mi nueva red en el más alto
tribunal del país los que se oponen a la
reelección de donald trump temen que un
balance de seis contra tres en el máximo
tribunal permita a los conservadores
revocar varias leyes históricas
incluyendo la ley de salud asequible
conocida como obamacare la juez verdad
dijo que no tenía ideas preconcebidas
no soy hostil al obamacare oa cualquiera
estatuto que se apruebe no es el caso yo
aplico la ley y sigo la ley ustedes
hacen la política también es clave para
quienes se oponen a su nominación el
dictamen de 1973 que dio a las mujeres
estadounidenses el derecho al aborto en
el pasado donald trump dijo que
nombraría jueces que ayudarían a revocar
esa ley y emi con nueva red a firmado
peticiones dando constancia de su
postura pro vida pero cuando fue
cuestionada sobre el tema esquivó la
pregunta
y expresó una opinión sobre un
precedente de una manera u otra es una
señal para las partes de que podría
inclinarme de una manera u otra en un
caso pendiente es es preocupante no
obtener una respuesta directa de nuevo
no puedo comprometerme de antemano a
decir si voy a entrar con alguna agenda
porque no es así no tengo ninguna agenda
no tengo ninguna agenda para tratar de
derogar a casey tengo una agenda para
pegarme al estado de derecho y decidir
los casos como vengan aunque se me voy a
hacer comentarios
ella dijo que no se ha comprometido con
nadie incluyendo el senado o la casa
blanca